I'd like to now show you two
mathematical facts about how we
integrate quantities of motion suppose
we have an object let's call the CI hat
direction and it's moving and it has an
X component of velocity and suppose it
starts at some initial position and goes
at some final position and in the
initial position it was at time T I and
the final position was at t final now we
have two very important integrals that
we want to look at which govern how we
describe how we apply integrate
acceleration with respect to time and
also how we'll integrate
acceleration with respect to space now
recall that our acceleration which may
be a function of time is the derivative
of the X component of velocity with
respect to time so let's first look at a
simple integration of acceleration with
respect to time and see what we get so
if we integrate acceleration I'm going
to introduce an integration variable DT
Prime and our integration variable goes
from our initial time to some final time
and if we use our fact that acceleration
is the derivative of velocity then we
can write this as DV X DT prime DT Prime
again after a while I'll drop the dummy
variables and the endpoints of the
integral and this simply becomes the
integral from t prime T initial T prime
equals T final of DV X Prime now notice
we've done a change of variables in
integration so instead of now talking
about the endpoints of the integral from
T prime T initial to T final now what
we're doing is we changed our
integration variable and so what we have
is we have the velocity integration
variable is going from some initial
value and that integration variable is
going to some final value so again our
initial conditions may have some initial
velocity and some final velocity three
different ways of describing the initial
and final States
this integral is a very straightforward
integral DX final minus VX initial which
is the change in the X component of the
velocity and that's our classic result
that we've done that the integration of
acceleration with respect to time is a
change in velocity now let's see what
happens is a comparison when we
integrate our acceleration not with
respect to time but suppose that it's a
function of space and so now we're
integrating again we have a dummy
variable we have to be careful because
this is the X component of acceleration
but X prime is our integration variable
and that's going from some initial
position to some final position now we
can write this as again make the
substitution DX DT DX prime going from
the initial to the final but now notice
we're going to rewrite this integrand as
DV x times DX prime DT prime DT and when
we do that we have this result that DX
prime DT prime is precisely what we mean
by V X now I'll introduce some dummy
variables there as well so what our
integrand becomes is DV X prime VX prime
that's not a function those are it's a
product of an integrand of it
differential times VX Prime and now our
new integration variable is going from
some integral
initial value to some final value once
again this is a straightforward integral
for those who haven't seen integrals
like this it's just something like X DX
is x squared over 2
but our integration variable is VX Prime
so what we get is one-half VX final
squared minus VX initial Square and so
what we see here is two fundamentally
different facts that if you integrate
acceleration with respect to time you
get the change in velocity but if you
integrate acceleration with respect to
space you get 1/2
time's the change not a velocity but of
the X component of the velocity squared
and both of these facts are central to
how we'll analyze the concept of work
and how we applied Newton's second law